so I think the calendar of the future
has to in some ways disappear into the
background I don't know how and when
that happens but it has to no longer be
a now I go to my calendar and think
about
calendaring I have to really get to a
place where it is seamlessly woven into
the other tasks that I'm doing what the
analysts love to call contextual
collaboration the calendar hasn't quite
succumbed to contextual collaboration
yet part of it is the PDA or mobile
device mentality
of okay let me just check my calendar do
I have that time available but you know
in a in an iPad or you know that kind of
device configuration it's I have to stop
what I'm doing click the big button go
over to my calendar get to the day that
I'm looking there's like 17 steps to go
be productive in the calendar whereas it
should be I'm looking at a document and
now I need to know if I'm July 18th I
can do something with that document um
so our thinking in Project Vulcan and
lots of other people's thinking in you
know some of the projects we see right
now is how do you get away from that
task orientation and much more to a
process orientation or contextual
orientation um I don't know I've worked
with calendaring for what did we say 15
16 years and it hasn't happened yet um I
think there will still because of the
nature of the calendar driving my my
activity still be a discreet activity
but it should get more integrated into
other things and then I think the other
question that really has to be answered
is how much sharing do I end up doing I
think in most companies still people
don't make their calendar wide open they
don't let people see what they're
working on and there has to be a way to
make that socially acceptable in the
company just like it has been to share
my documents and share my knowledge
right because I mean we've gone down
this curve and in collaboration in
general when we started shipping noes 20
years ago we had to teach companies why
it would be good to share the
information that everybody had in the
company most companies were my knowledge
is my value to the company and so our
first nodes customers actually had to
put incentive programs in place for
humans to get compensated for putting
stuff into notes
databases it's kind of the same with
calendars I still don't really feel
comfortable telling people what am I
spending my time on every day my own
staff though probably could really
benefit from seeing which customers I'm
meeting what projects I'm spent choosing
to spend my time on what are my
priorities more than at a once a month
staff meeting or whatever so there's
still a cultural barrier and I see that
in lots of our customers and I think it
just stems from the personal nature of
calendaring and that's probably the last
piece that I would say kind of in the
future we still have to address as an
industry I get as a vendor more feature
requests for calendar than any other
part of our messaging collaboration
because calendaring is an intensely
personal activity how I want to operate
is different than how the next person
wants to operate and it's different in
Japan and it's different in Israel and
it's different in Germany and you know
we build a horizontal product right so
you know we almost shipped notes version
8 without the ability to see the week
number in the notes8 calendar and at the
last minute I basically stopped the ship
because we hadn't put that feature in
and we had planned to put it in later I
said you can't ship a calendar without
week number support for the German
Market because they drive events around
well in week 17 we're going to do X or
in Japan they really want to view
calendars horizontally and not
vertically because of the cultural
hierarchy within the the country or in
you know Hebrew it's got to really go
right to left and the work day has to
work week has to start on Sunday not on
Monday and you know so the feature
requests are constant because there are
cultural differences around the world
and every individual has a feeling of
how they want to do it and then the
other impact is every new device that
comes out has a different way of
calendaring and so people want to borrow
the best and worst for me right now my
big inflection point is as I keep
looking at it my iPad sitting over there
great calendar system apple as always
has done a really great job on usability
but guess what there's no free time
search there's no ability to counter
propose there's no ability to delegate a
meeting to somebody else I can't even
send comments in if I accept a meeting
there's there's nothing it's Yes No
Maybe So really great interface but
because they've narrow the scope so much
on what they're going to actually try to
accomplish well of course if I was
building a simple calendar interface
it'd look pretty hot right now too but
if I'm trying to build one that does
everything you know it's more
complicated which uh which brings me to
another Point uh and it actually I think
it it brings in a few subjects at the
same time you've got privacy of
information what you're willing to sh
share with other people and so on you've
got you know um if you look at the Notes
Calendar you look at Outlook calendar
you look at you know all these different
calendars you take out the logo they
pretty much all look the same you know
7-Day Grid or depending on the
visualization want a day or a week
orever pretty much the look is the same
you think uh and that grid view I mean
before people had day planners so it
wasn't really a grid View you know it
was dat planners and you had Monday to
and then but then when we went uh on the
PC we started to have the grid
view uh and it hasn't really evolved
yeah um do you think that's going to
evolve do you think people are willing
to evolve and if so how do you think
that will evolve there's a lot of PC
metaphors that are still stuck in some
past experience and I I often think it's
kind of one of the you know spare
daydreaming things that I I sit there
and think about if we didn't have this
installed base what would we do
differently I mean you can you can do
that about anything my my favorite one
is if we didn't have stop lights today
red yellow green simple lights on a pole
what would if in 2010 if you had a bunch
of Traffic Engineers try to come up with
a traffic control signal for an
intersection would they come up with
three little lights on a
post no no way so but that's what we
have right that's what we have in 2010
we're stuck with it because you're never
going to teach the whole world some
different metaphor right and you know
even in 2010 the metaphor of a folder
within your mail or the icon to save in
most applications still looks like a
floppy disc and I haven't seen a
physical floppy disc in at least you
know 10 years right um so we get stuck
in these metaphors of the past because
of the curse of the install base and
that's no offense to anybody's an user
but when you've trained millions of
people to do something teaching them to
do it a different way is is really a
challenge so again as slick as an iPad
or a Blackberry or whatever is today in
2010 they've still stuck with the
metaphors that Computing industry and
invented 10 or 20 years ago it will take
some major inflection activity to get
people comfortable doing it some other
way and I think activity based may be
the way to do that but we've been
talking about that now what do you mean
by activity based like so I'm more
focused on this project and this thing
that I want to work on than some time
slot and some email that somebody sent
me and we but we've been talking about
that concept within our research team
for six years now some of it's in our
product today but we still can't get to
a metaphor that's different it still
ties to the existing tools and
systems it could be that there's a
better way out there and our researchers
have some really good ideas but even
when I see them do new research projects
they still start with a grid in
calendaring so I think that it's going
to be some major inflection event maybe
it's around location services maybe it's
around some Cloud thing that we don't
know of yet um that you think the mobile
can play a role in there I think
Mobile's probably the the key there
right because mobile is where the
Innovation is happening right now faster
than I can write software I can write I
can see mobile devices with six-month
lifespan coming out with new interfaces
and new
capabilities
so if that's the place where it will
happen you know consumer adoption
happens there as well and and that's the
thing driving a lot of it is the end
user can go buy their own mobile device
in most companies right so I can choose
to adopt an iPhone I can choose to adopt
a Blackberry I can choose to adopt a
Nokia nobody's choosing to adopt Windows
mobile but anyway sorry
um uh but as an end user if I'm making
that choice I'm making that choice based
on oh Android has these really great
features but oh by the way Android
doesn't have a calendar that's built
into the operating system yet and even
in proo 2.2 they have some sort of vague
day to glance thing and personal
calendar but they don't have an
Enterprise calendar function build so
now it's up to us as a vendor to go fill
that b right so every device is doing
things different and now that more of
them have an app store model where a
user can put their own stuff on there
users will adopt what makes sense to
them I don't like the way that Twitter
looks so I'll go to flipbook I don't you
know I'm not really excited about um you
know the Faceook app as it's installed
I'm going to go to some different UI
right um I could use the browser for
half these things but the apps have
actually made it much more interesting
or useful right the New York Times
publishes a perfectly good website but
they have an app on there that takes
that website and formats it specifically
for the iPad so I'm using that so I
think that users will Pro it along but I
don't know what the thing is that
they're going to latch on to have you
tried flip board by the way yeah what do
you think I I think it's great it's
awesome man I mean it's the same
information that we're used to seeing
every day is just displayed differently
and people are like I never knew had
that information well the thing that
they did that smart is they go one level
down in the links yeah right because
half those links that you see in a
Twitter stream you'd probably never
click on but all of a sudden you're
reading the article or summary of the
article and go oh that's pretty
interesting so this morning I learned
some guy in Switzerland got a speeding
ticket for a million dollars uh based on
driving his Mercedes around at 200 miles
an hour somewhere in in Switzerland and
the fine system in Switzerland is based
on uh the income of the person who got
stopped and all sorts of things so this
guy was 600,000 pounds so about a
million US Dollars um speeding ticket
and it was on my Twitter stream and it
was on Facebook and it was on Tech
crunch so all of them came together in
Flipboard so that's interesting yeah I I
really think that you know there there's
ways that you know we're used to our
calendar grd and that's not going to
that's going to change yeah um because
it's ingraining everybody and and and
and um but I do think that there's place
for Innovation on visualization and it
depends on what you like for example
like the ability you talked about the
ability to suggest stuff to
do you won't have that pop up from a
from a square and your there's got to be
a different way of visualizing what you
could be doing during that time and then
how does that link back into the grid
and then how do you get out of it or you
know you travel a lot right and and
there's if if if I'm in the office yeah
the grid works for me but if I'm
traveling I would like to see my day in
a totally different format for example
where I want to see my itinerary this is
where you're going to be going this is
you know and and and these These are the
routes you're going to have to take and
this is the time that you have to
estimate so by the way don't book a
meeting during that or you can do only a
phone call or whatever your int your
calendar should be intelligent for you
right yeah we're starting to take steps
in that direction but but it really does
all have to come together and and you
know overlays don't do that yet they're
not intelligent enough to look at each
other um so it's still oh well I have
that meeting from 1 to two and then I
need a drive time and then I need a this
and a bio break and yeah how are we
going to schedule those in there right
yeah